my name is sammy and i am a pediatric
oncology and bone marrow transplant
nurse at the children's hospital of
philadelphia i have two children right
now my almost four-year-old daughter
jordan and a little five-month-old baby
girl that we are fostering
working with children who are sick is
definitely
emotionally challenging but it's also
what fuels me and i find it very
rewarding to
meet patients and their families in
their most vulnerable place
when i was a brand new nurse i had a
patient who asked me if i would foster
her
and i knew because of professional
boundaries i couldn't but she's what
motivated me to start the application
process and as soon as i got my license
i started getting placements within the
same week
the goal in foster care should always be
to reunify the children with their
biological families so when my daughter
was placed with me eventually the goal
did shift to
adoption
thankfully we have a really magical and
beautiful relationship with some of her
biological relatives and that has been a
blessing i think for everybody we face
time with her grandmother multiple times
a week and then oftentimes with jordan's
biological brothers as soon as it's safe
to travel one of our first stops is
going to be florida to see them
in 2018 i founded camp 2b long river
valley
and our mission is to reunite brothers
and sisters who have been separated
because of foster care if we can create
a place where we can support siblings to
build a strong foundation and have a
healthy sibling relationship even when
they're going through a traumatic event
that we should create this place if i'm
being fully transparent my days are long
and tiring but
just keep forging ahead because
the children they're the heroes in
everything that i do and they are what
keep me going on a day-to-day basis
um
i have to say i really appreciated how
that piece ends and i watched it earlier
and you admit that it's hard
and yet now that i'm a mother of two
kids are incredibly inspiring is is that
what gets you through
absolutely my kids are what fill me up
and they keep me going and motivate me
every single day because
just to see them it it fills me um is it
true
that when you were a kid you watched e.t
and like you were watching the film and
like something happened to you like
while he was like in the medical area
that is true i was pretty young i
vividly recall watching that movie and
it was the scene where
they were worried about him getting
hypothermia and they were like getting a
nasal cannula and his pupils were fixed
and dilated and i of course didn't know
what that meant but it started the
snowball of like mom and dad what does
this mean and i just was drawn to that
scene and i was like okay i'm definitely
going into healthcare
you're amazing and i'm so glad that
there are people on this planet who
think and feel and walk the walk and
live like you do you really are the
epitome
of what we want to celebrate on this
show and
then there's a whole other angle to it
you founded this camp to belong river
valley
and you reunite siblings
who have been placed in the foster care
system
who
are looking to find each other let alone
reconnect will you tell me about the
camp sure
um so in america there's approximately
over 400 000 children living in foster
care at any given time and over 75
percent of those children are separated
from at least one of their siblings and
so i just
felt like there needed to be this safe
place where we can bring siblings
together and truly create an environment
where they feel like they can belong and
create happy memories
i mean
you are you're such
a complete inspiration and i just want
to thank you for everything that you do
truly i i admire you more than words
could ever convey
i am i wanted in some way to get
involved you said that you were hoping
to get to florida to reunite your
daughter jordan with some of her
biological relatives and we've teamed up
with the islands beaches and
neighborhoods of fort myers and florida
to give you a five-day four night trip
to south seas island resort on captiva
island because it's always a good day
when you visit fort myers and sammy it's
a good day for us because we had the
privilege of meeting you and hearing
your story and being inspired of a way
to live a life you are extraordinary
[Music]